you're welcome to this video playing la
kazoo from Norway and 22 something rated
yeah my rating is so very very much down
to two three or seven that's really a
disgrace okay but the dog it's all the
result of good play or bed play okay
then cut off this strange line with 94
but they have a really tremendous core
with that so I welcome welcome to sly
okay let's see what happens yep is
Bishop before sm no snow in the air well
this is this is a very
ambitious way to play check knight 2000
to Knight to c3 can I have this five
idea pushing pushing my Kings I pawns
yeah and now f4 interesting of course
he's got this porn power in the center
so it's not not completely one-sided
this I really don't believe this looks
looks very very dangerous for white
f3 is the idea combined with bishop h3
ideas
hmm i don't really i have yeah he can
play I don't know never think of the
year does this you cannot afford I
cannot believe this in the slightest
Queen g4 now threatened that is you
cannot defend this I don't think so just
attacking with all pieces g3 queen age 3
is an immediate mate ya light resigned
it's simply not not working but what he
did here this is actually debatable if
this is a good good idea for black but
it's interesting it's an interesting set
up and it went downhill really quickly
yeah this is not working you're the
computer instantly shows black like
winning here yeah but ok this is far too
yeah I don't know what what to call this
move I mean you need to really take care
about blacks Fred cm maybe a three-year
something like this this is interesting
like has some much play I mean but check
this kind of stuff yeah this is this is
a really powerful it is very dangerous
for white but you of course could have
defended much more tenaciously alright
thanks for watching